[Musique]
c'est une histoire plutôt étonnante qui
vient d'être révélée à la presse un
homme condamné à verser plus de 200000
euros à son ex-femme parce qu'elle
s'occupait seul des tâches ménagères
tandis que son mari lui interdisait de
travailler une mère de famille c'est
pendant près de 25 ans
occupé seul des tâches ménagères je me
consacrer exclusivement à m'occuper de
mon mari à m'occuper de la maison alors
que 73% des françaises estiment faire
davantage de tâches ménagères que leurs
conjoint le tribunal de Malaga vient de
prendre une décision condamnée l'ex-mari
de cet Espagnol à lui verser plus de
200000 euros à titre de compensation
pour ses tâches ménagères effectuées à
la maison pendant plus de 20 ans
un homme qui n'avait pas assez participé
aux tâches ménagères condamnées à verser
200000 euros à son ex-femme
comprenez-vous cette décision
ah ouais c'est le plaisir de voir
Béatrice durant la téloche
[Rires]
vous comprenez bravo pour cette décision
le gars possédait des salles de sport
elle allait faire monitrice gratuitement
bénévolement il lui donnait rien non
mais c'est honteux ce qu'elle a subi
Cyril il était temps qu'un justice soit
réparé non non
d'accord
je suis avec la régie OK
vers quelle heure ok d'accord
20h25
[Applaudissements]
à sa femme de s'occuper de la maison si
elle est d'accord évidemment en revanche
il faut prendre soin d'elle là le mec
c'est une barre de fer il lâchait pas un
euro il l'empêchait de travailler
ailleurs il la faisait bosser gratos
donc au bout d'un moment c'est normal
qu'il rentre l'argent qui rend de la
Moula c'est normal c'est la salle de
sport moi c'est la salle de sport qui me
dérange qu'il a fasse bosser dans ces
salles de sport s'il y avait pas eu ça
s'il y avait pas eu elle va travailler
dans toutes ses salles de sport si
c'était juste parce qu'elle a fait le
ménage et pendant que lui il est au
boulot je ne sais quoi si on commence
tout ça donner 200000 euros ça va faire
mal il faut qu'elle ait quoi
au foyer attaquent leur mari
faut s'occuper d'elle ben oui